الى تطورات في السودان حيث تجددت
الاشتباكات في مدن العاصمه وقال الجيش انه
وجه ضربات لمن وصفهم بالمتمردين في جنوب
ام درمان ووسط الخرطوم بحري في المقابل
اعلنت قوات الدعم السريعه تصديها لهجوم من
وصفتهم بالقوات الانقلابيه في زار نجيب
ولايه وسط دارفور
من جهته قال الامين العام للامم المتحده
في السودان قد تدهور بشكل كبير نتيجه
للاشتباكات التي تدور بين الجيش وقوه
الدعم السريعه واضاف غوتيريش في تقريره
الدوري ان اعمال العنف اثرت بشكل سلبي
للغايه على الاوضاع الانسانيه حيث توقفت
الانشطه الانسانيه في عده ولايات بسبب
انعدام الامن على نطاق واسع واكد ان
القتال لا يزال متواصلا بلا هواده على
الرغم من المحاولات المستمره لحمل الطرفين
على وقف الاعمال القتاليه والعوده الى
المفاوضات كما وصف الامين العام حاله
المدنيين المحاصرين في المناطق الحضاريه
والذين يتعرضون للهجمات واطلاق النار
والقصف اليومي وصفها بانها غير مقبوله
ومثيره للقلق